[Music]
from Ann Curry's awkward exit to al
Roker's joke of throwing people under
the bus here's a look at the 7 most
shocking Today Show moments including
Matt Lauer's termination
[Music]
when the Today Show reported Amy
Winehouse's death back in 2011 from
music video for you know I'm no good
played but the caption you know I'm dead
underneath the following year Kathie Lee
Gifford made the cringe-worthy mistake
of asking Martin Short how long he and
his wife Nancy Dolman had been together
completely unaware and Nancy had died
back in 2010 I mean Nancy have gotten
one of the greatest marriages of anybody
in show business how many years now for
you guys we married 36 years but you're
still like in love madly in love why Jim
I'm cute and Currie gave this awkwardly
tearful goodbye just one year after
becoming co-anchor of the hit NBC show
and 15 years after joining the team
rumors swirled the reason behind her
departure had much to do with her
co-anchor Matt Lauer most importantly
you've made us better and we thank you
from the bottom of our heart thank you
so much thank you thank you
not long after Curry's fellow anchor and
friend Al Roker made this comment live
on television which many assumed it was
a jab at Lauer does it throw one of us
under the bus to Roker in late 2012 and
Hathaway suffered a wardrobe malfunction
while arriving at the lay mazhab
premiere here's how Lauer addressed it
on-air seen a lot of you lately but I'm
sorry that we live in a culture that
commodified sexuality of unwilling
participants the Today Show once had a
moment of mistaken identity during an
interview with Michael Vick they rolled
footage of Philadelphia Eagles
quarterback Jared Johnson the 7th and
possibly biggest scandal of all flowers
firing in late November 2017 the anchor
was let go from the show after over 20
years when allegations of sexual
misconduct in the workplace surfaced and
his current co-anchor Savannah Guthrie
reported the news live on air this is a
sad morning here at today and at NBC
News